there's a lot of anxiety in the country  and as a result we're not hearing each  other we're not talking to each other we  stick with like-minded people and have  lost our ability to appreciate that  someone's life experience may be very  different than yours what I tried to do  with this series is to not judge people  but to encourage an open honest dialogue  actually listen to each other be  critical thinkers and be open-minded  these are really complicated topics to  unpack white anxiety gender inequality  tech addiction I don't think this series  is going to change the world but I'm  hoping it will help people see a  different perspective America inside out  with Katie Couric Wednesday April 11th  attend on National Geographic want more  exclusive content from America inside  out we'll just click one of these videos  floating next to me